(ﾃﾞﾚﾃｯﾃﾝ♫)
(ﾃﾞﾚﾃｯﾃﾞﾚﾃﾝｯ♫)
(ﾋﾟﾛﾘﾗ~~~~♫)
(ﾃﾞﾚﾃｯﾃﾝ♫)
(ﾃﾞﾚﾃｯﾃﾞﾚﾃﾝ♫)
(ﾃﾞﾚｯﾃｯﾃﾝ♫)
(ﾋﾟﾛﾙﾙ~~~↘)
(ｶｶﾎﾟﾝｶｯﾎﾟﾝ♫)
(頭を叩く音）
(ﾃﾞﾚﾃｯﾃﾝ♫)
一同）はいどうも～～～～！！！
一同）今日は！！
一同）なんと！！！
一同）なんとですねぇ～～～！！！！！
はじめ）すき家！全メニューでーーす！！！！
一同）うわぁあああああ～～！！！！
は）や、でも今日はもう４人体制でやるから～
は）いつも２人でやってるけど
は）今日はもう４人なんで
は）今日は、ちょっと、ほんとに！
は）変な奴らを呼んだのでもう
は）クラスにいたら目立って女子から嫌われるような
は）男子を連れてきたので！！
マホト）ﾊﾊｧｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｗｗｗ
てつや）その通り！大正解すぎる！！！
は）結構あるとは思うんですけど～
は）意外といけそうなんすよ！
は）だけどもうね、つべこべ言わずに！
は）今回こそは！！
は）もう全部食ってね！
マ）今回こそはね！
は）今回こそは！
は）そろそろっ！
しばゆー）やってやりましょう
は）バシッと決めなきゃね！
し）歴史変えましょう！
は）全メニュー！
は）喰っていこうとおもいます！
マ）よしっ！！！！
は）っしゃ行こう！！！！
マ）っしゃあ！！
は）っしゃ！
て）しゃちょーって今まで
て）達成したシリーズなんかあります？？
は）無い…
一同）ｱｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊﾊﾊﾊｗｗ
マ）ふざけてんのか！
マ）いただきまーす。
は）いただきます！
し）＄♪×￥●＆％
し）あ、うめっ！
マ）ちょうどいいです。
は）今！２時…１４時でございます
は）丁度、お昼…ﾍﾟｯ
は）あぶねっ
は）丁度、お昼時で~す
マ）口ゆるっ！
一同）ﾌﾌｯｗｗ
マ）ご飯やるよお前に
し）ウェｯ?!!!
し）まじか！？
は）この最初にくる～
は）美味しさからの沈黙ですこれが
マ）あぁ～
マ）じゃあもうご飯やるよ
し）ｳﾝﾝﾝﾝﾝ~~~?!!!!
は）ちゃんと汁ものも！買ってあります
マ）ﾊﾊﾊﾊｯｗｗｗｗ
マ）何しとんだお前、食事中やろうがお前
は）チーズのってんじゃあ”ぁ”ん！！！
は）柴田それ飲みたい
は）何で炭酸水飲んでんの？！
て）ﾌﾌｯｗｗｗ
は）お腹ふくれん？！
は）ｯﾊｗ
し）ｱｧｯ！！！！
て）勝手にこれ全種類できないんじゃね？
マ）ﾌﾌﾌﾌﾌｗｗｗｗ
マ）何でお前飲んでんだよ！！ｗ
マ）あ、デザート！デザートしよ～
て）えっ今？！
し）えっ？！
て）早い早い早い…
し）ずるい！
は）マホトおれも何かとって！
マ）いいよ～
ﾊｧｰ　ﾌｩ~…
し）（咳き込んでいる）
て）１回うん１回うんｋ…
マ）しばゆー吐いてね？！
て）(せき込み）
て）１回うんこしてぇ
マ）ｱﾊﾊﾊﾊﾊｯ!!ｗｗ
マ）あいつ吐いてるぞ！！！ｗｗ
マ）こっちが食欲無くなんだわな
は）確かにある
マ）それ聞いてると
は）あぁやばい！！
マ）顔よ！！！！！！ｗｗｗ
し）やばい、ダメだ…
マ）ｱﾊﾊｗｗ
し）や、でもこれで食えます！
は）おぉ！！
て）（咳き込み）
て）喉が…
マ）ってか帰る？
て）普通に帰ります？じゃあ
マ）うん
マ）帰る！
は）ちょっとまってまってまってｗ
は）ほんとにやばいマジで
し）東京帰ります？
は）まってまってまってまってまって…
は）これただのバカになるよこれ
マ）ゴミ、すまんね！
は）えマジで言ってんの？！
マ）ゴミ、すまんね…
て）しゃちょー！
て）お世話になりました！
て）またよろしくお願いいたします！
し）お疲れさまでした！
マ）お疲れっした！
し）ありがとうございました！
て）また来ま～す
し）また来ます
し）あ、ゴミすいません…
て）あ、ほんと、すいません…
は）いいよいいよ
て）お願いします